In this segment, we consider
the sum of independent Poisson
random variables, and we
establish a remarkable fact,
namely that the sum
is also Poisson.
This is a fact that
we can establish
by using the
convolution formula.
The PMF of the sum of
independent random variables
is the convolution
of their PMFs.
So we can take two Poisson
PMFs, convolve them, carry out
the algebra, and find
out that in the end,
you obtain again a Poisson PMF.
However, such a derivation
is completely unintuitive,
and does not give
you any insight.
Instead, we will
derive this fact
by using our
intuition about what
Poisson random variables
really represent.
We will work with
a Poisson process
of rate lambda equal to 1.
But let us remind ourselves
of the general Poisson PMF
if we have a more
general rate lambda.
This is the PMF of
the number of arrivals
in a Poisson process with
rate lambda during a time
interval of length tau.
And this Poisson PMF has a
mean equal to lambda tau.
And you can think of
lambda tau as being
the parameter of
this Poisson PMF.
So we say that this is a
Poisson PMF with parameter
equal to lambda times tau.
Now, let us consider two
consecutive time intervals
in this processes that
have length mu and nu.
And let us consider
the numbers of arrivals
during each one of
these intervals.
So we have M arrivals
here and N arrivals there.
Of course, M and N
are random variables.
What kind of random
variables are they?
Well, the number of arrivals in
the Poisson process of rate 1,
over a period of
duration mu is going
to have a Poisson PMF in
which lambda is one, tau,
the time interval
is equal to mu,
so it's going to be a Poisson
random variable with parameter,
or mean, equal to mu.
Similarly for N, it's going to
be a Poisson random variable
with parameter equal to nu.
Are these two random
variables independent?
Of course they are.
In a Poisson
process, the numbers
of arrivals in
disjoint time intervals
are independent
random variables.
What kind of random
variable is their sum?
Their sum is the total
number of arrivals
during an interval
of length mu plus nu,
and therefore this is a
Poisson random variable
with mean equal to mu plus nu.
So, what do we have here?
We have the sum of two
independent Poisson random
variables, and that
sum turns out also
to be a Poisson random variable.
More generally, if
somebody gives you
two independent Poisson
random variables,
you can always think of
them as representing numbers
of arrivals in disjoint
time intervals,
and therefore by
following this argument,
their sum is going to be
a Poisson random variable.
And this is the conclusion
that we wanted to establish.
It's a remarkable fact.
It's similar to the fact
that we had established
for normal random variables.
The sum of independent
normal random variables
is also normal, so Poisson
and normal distributions
are special in this respect.
This is a property that most
other distributions do not
have, with very few exceptions.